they simply don't believe that when two
people trade one is not ripping the
other off hey there it's Kennedy with
reason TV having to sit down with matt
ridley zoologist author ingenious we're
going to talk about ideas having sex I
like that idea so you've got this notion
in the book the rational optimist how
prosperity evolves explain briefly what
that is before we get into the naughty
ideas I'm optimistic because of the
facts not because of some spiritual
disposition in other words I was brought
up to think that the world was going to
be a disaster in my lifetime you know
the population explosion famine now
Malthus all that kind of thing and it
didn't turn out that way in fact in my
lifetime the income of the average
person on the planet has trebled in real
terms child mortality is down by
two-thirds life span is up by thirty
percent these are incredible changes in
human living standards and they blew me
away when I began to research this and
to work it out so I'm rational in my
optimism in the sense that i'm looking
at the facts i'm looking at the data i'm
looking at the argument hand i'm trying
to understand where it's coming from i'm
trying to understand what what drives
human prosperity what is it that
increases it is that about to stop i
don't think so why does everyone want to
throw a wet blanket on that notion of
prosperity and evolution which you know
obviously they go hand in hand and they
want to make us believe that the world
is unfair the earth is sick and we're
all going to die horrible deaths because
of our own causes people have a very
strong interest in in saying but when
you say that things are getting better
and there's a very nice example of this
the other day which was that maternal
mortality was falling for a long time
then it stopped falling globally and it
stopped falling because of the AIDS
epidemic and a lot of African mothers
were dying because they had AIDS and
they died during or around childbirth
and then it then the full resumed and
there was a paper in the lancet medical
magazine saying this fall has resumed
mainly because we're getting on top of
the AIDS epidemic now and the editor of
The Lancet came out to pressure not to
publish that paper
because all the groups working on
maternal mortality didn't want to see
their grant funding threatened I'm so
cynical it which i think is crazy I see
all the way around you should say look
what a good job we're doing we're
getting it done so give us some more
money if they want to do okay but that
to me is an idea bad ideas having sex
that yield those results it's true that
bad ideas can meet and mate and produce
more ideas just as much as good ideas
can but not quite as much because you
see the problem is that the the for
these ideas to spread you know for a new
idea for an innovation or an invention
to spread people have got to like it
it's got to do something for them there
are people trying to spread bad ideas
that are bad for people and trying to
promulgate things that you know
dictators and and others you know
subversives and and people are just you
know foolish and have got the wrong idea
nonetheless on the whole the good ideas
do win in the long run and if you look
around the world that's what's happening
what's going to happen with global
climate change because I know you say
that you're a lukewarm or you said
there's no evidence that climate is
changing dangerously or faster than in
the past when it changed naturally I
agree with that sentence and it seems
like most rationalist do but there's so
much money to be made with all the doom
and gloom surrounding global climate
change yeah well my position on climate
changes has evolved I first wrote about
it 25 years ago in that for the
economist at that time I was a fairly
standard alarmist I thought wow this is
scary this cub dark side effect and
gradually I've come to know the data
better and better and I've further I've
drilled into it the more convinced I am
that the cure is worse than the disease
in other words yes there's a risk of
climate change going catastrophic but
that risk is getting smaller all the
time as more years pass and as we as we
get to know the sensitivity of the
atmosphere and it's extremely small that
risk so this is quite different from
saying climate change doesn't happen or
that human beings are not causing it
partly I think they probably are i think
i think the greenhouse effect is real
but it only produces a mild effect the
positive feedbacks are not there so the
bottom line is on this issue we are
taking chemotherapy for a cold we're
putting a tourney k round our neck to
stop
nosebleed it's going to work in the
sense that the nosebleeds going to stop
but it's going to kill us do you think
the notion of the fair share and and
people owing their fair share and people
deserving their fair share is that going
to go away anytime soon I think people
are always going to be exercised about
inequality and perhaps rightly so
because back in the Stone Age inequality
resulted in you not getting laid and
somebody else getting laid you see what
I mean you know that was that was the
effect of having fewer resources than
someone else so it's always you know in
our psyches it's a really big issue
where relativists in this respect we
don't care how poor everybody is as long
as we're top of the heap so this isn't
there a justification for that if we're
seeking out the resources if you can
come to it from an evolutionary
perspective doesn't that basically take
the morality out of it I think something
to get here is that the inequality
global inequality is going down at the
moment it's not going up it's going down
or the evidence is pretty clear on this
it's and the reason is because poor
countries are getting rich faster than
rich countries of getting rich it's
particularly true over the last five
years since the Great Recession because
India and China have stormed ahead while
Europe and America have stagnated so
although inequality can be rising in
China and rising in America global
inequality is going down that's great
aren't we dealing with people who think
that it's a zero-sum game I think that's
absolutely right that a big problem with
the world is that human beings find
positive some games difficult to
understand they they simply don't
believe that when two people trade one
is not ripping the other off they are my
can't lists in that sense they think
that that exports are good and inputs
are bad or whatever and they think that
when they go into a shop you know either
this guy's exploiting me or I'm
exploiting him there's two plus two
equals five phenomenon which goes back
to Ricardo's law of comparative
advantage and is is the great theme of
human history and it's what we've done
we've got more specialized as producers
more diversified as consumers in order
to work for each other and raise each
other's living this is an extraordinary
phenomenon it's one that people find
intuitively very hard to grasp they
still think it's a zero-sum game that
the sum heap of wealth out there and if
I'd
make a bigger shovel than you I get more
than you all right thank you so much
matt ridley and thank you for watching
this is kennedy for recent TV